[Music]
it's time for et's social study your
quick look at what the stars are posting
online this is a this is a relatively
inexpensive snack it tastes good
my life is terrible I mean life is
beautiful
in some it was a Chris Pratt posted
another hilarious and healthy
hashtag what's my snack video to
Instagram joking about his fit bod in
the caption like I always said eating is
no longer the fun part flexing my butt
cheeks in the mirrors cuz no dimples no
rolls just cutout butt cheeks live with
it you're standing at the mouth of hell
you've got to be ready oh we're ready
for a Buffy the Vampire Slayer reunion
Entertainment Weekly shared the first
photos on social media Wednesday of the
cast back together for the April cover
of the mag which includes Sarah Michelle
Gellar and David Boreanaz meanwhile Rob
Kardashian posted two adorable photos of
his five-month-old daughter dream
gushing in the caption babies are the
greatest gift of life I made this
beautiful little mama
[Music]
you